Steve's with us in Baton Rouge hi Steve
welcome with the Dave Ramsey show okay
thank you for taking my call today sure
what's up I had a question I'm in baby
step two and I've got three kids and one
of them has taken up gymnastics I had
some questions about the C's and what
maybe you thought I should do and baby
step two
she started out as a doing recreation
gymnastics and was $70 a month which was
fine but she's been excelling ever since
you got in there she's done really well
and they asked her to be on team
gymnastics and they told us initially it
was gonna be 170 dollars a month and I
agree to that and so we'll go ahead and
make make it work we'll make it happen
so I went ahead and we did that and it's
been slowly creeping up from 170 I'm
spending about $300 a month now for the
gymnastics plus it seems like everyone's
on all they throw extra fees in there
and it's just killing my budget I'm
trying to get a baby step - mm-hmm and
trying to side what to do my wife's on
disagreement of what to do on that I'm
starting to think maybe it's just a
little too much what's your heart right
now household income well I've got I've
got two jobs since I started your Dave
step two I picked up another job my main
job is about 85 with my second job it's
about 100
I've been working the last I've been
baby step 2 for 18 months now I paid off
44,000 debt mm-hmm and then working 65
and 90 hours a week and I'm I'm ready to
bring it in a little bit so I can be
home more so yeah and I'm gonna back
drink yeah how much debt have you got
left right now I've got 23,000 left and
I'm hoping to be done with baby steps
ooh a year or less
and your wife is not participating in
this he does this by myself no she she
is trying to follow the program with the
exception of gymnastics we gotta be
holders my daughter that's in gymnastics
she is six six years old
your wife is not gonna like me not $800
a month on a six-year-old while you're
having to work 90 hours a week is
asinine it's ridiculous really I mean
okay that's that's $4,000 a year at
least I mean what okay there's nothing
you if you weren't working overtime and
you guys were debt-free and all and you
wanted to spend this that that's fine I
still think it's asinine but it's fine
it's up to you to do that at that point
but dude this is not right
yes ma'am another thank you is she has
meats where she has to travel and well
sometimes they're out of state you know
we might be able to drive listen here
I'm back you know you're not training an
Olympian yes this is this is a child
that's supposed to be having fun
mmm and in your family right now is
trying to get out of that and you are
working like a madman you're working a
bazillion hours for a six-year-old to
Travis new gymnastics now you know I'm
probably gonna get hate mail off of this
and you're probably gonna get hate mail
when you get home because you know yeah
no no I mean you didn't agree to it they
change the tie they move the needle on
you yeah you guys sucked into the vortex
man I heard the story I went from 70 to
170 and 300 and now we're traveling and
so now we're up over 300 way over 300
when you include travel yes I mean you
don't know how much gonna cost you know
once you have those beats in these
cities that have all these them yeah I
know how much I know how much it's gonna
cost if it's my kids zero we're done I
understand we're done you can do
tumbling in the backyard kid and okay
just do your little somersault there
it's I'm sorry I that that's just it's
you know my son you know when we were
I coached him playing ice hockey he
started playing when he was four okay
and we didn't even play travel and it
really wasn't because he was good enough
to play travel but he was not good
enough to get in the NHL so we just made
a decision at our house we a weren't
gonna spend the money and B weren't
gonna spend every weekend running around
all over the US to watch a kid play
hockey when I can drive down here the
rink and watch him play hockey and he
had much fun doing that and he wasn't
going to be in the NHL number one didn't
want him to number two he wasn't good
enough and neither was his old man okay
so you know I mean this is about kids
having fun I understand if we do poor
out with this I'm she's gonna be mad at
me but she's six she'll be done mad at
ya there in the week okay you know I
mean it's she's six how long's she gonna
be mad this is a 16 year old can
remember something a year a six-year-old
can't and so I'm just an old guy that's
been this raised kids and now I got
grandkids running around and they're
just more resilient and it's just kids
having fun it's okay to spend money on
stuff like that for your kids if that's
what you want to do and you have the
money but you just don't have the money
dad is working himself into oblivion so
a six-year-old can tumble out of town
there's just something wrong with that
man I mean I'm sorry again I'm not gonna
be popular at your house and that's okay
I'll have to live with that I'm not
popular in some people's houses as it is
so and a bunch of you were sending me a
bunch of tweets right now I'm sure
something raising Cain with me right now
that's fine have at it I don't care this
is that's the beauty of this show so hey
I'm sorry man I'm not trying to be mean
to your baby I want your baby to have
fun but I'm just I'm kind of taking up
for you you're being a good man you're
serving your wife your kids you're
trying to do the grown-up thing and
getting this debt cleaned up and so your
family can have a future and your
working 90 hours a week to do that and
it's being offset by the kid doing
tumbling it just doesn't make sense to
me
so hey thanks for the call open phones
at Triple Eight eight two five five two
two five I am NOT against all kids or
cannot support so I'm not against I'm
against parents who get completely
freaking out of control or they get
sucked into this we did that which one
of ours was doing it oh it was Rachel
Rachel Denise from both cheerleaders
Rachel more so than a Nissen rachel was
little and so what was it they called
she was the one to jump up on top and
then they throw her off oh the flyer she
was the flyer
she would fly and so then she goes down
here and takes cheerleading class which
never made sense to me at all but I did
I went a long way they don't we had the
money and then they wanted to do
competition cheerleading class and the
kids like 13 years old and it was
hundreds and hundreds of dollars I'm
just livid Sharon you had the money I
don't care if I have the money it's just
dumb to me we're not doing it so we
didn't do competition cheerleading
either so we might have for a month or
two but it just didn't last
I just can't wow you just you just gotta
decide where your values are it's okay
if you guys want to do that and you have
the money you can do whatever you want
there I'm not mad at you about it but
the thing is when you're having to make
financial choices like working overtime
and working extra jobs because of stuff
like that that's when your year you've
gotten the thing out of control it's out
of balance and so that's my story and
I'm sticking to it
again you don't like it okay turn the
bow get you something else to listen to